voilà la première c'est le 2 septembre
j'enlève le haut le 4 septembre j'enlève
le bas alors moi je m'en souviens quand
même magnifique on était tous comme des
malades et le 4 septembre voilà ce qu'on
voit donc
l'affichage qui tient ses promesses
et notre invité du samedi 20h ce soir
Yuma mudra bonsoir
alors durant l'été 1981 la France
découvre une campagne de publicité sans
précédent regardez
voilà le 12 septembre j'enlève le haut
ensuite le 4 septembre j'enlève le bas
et enfin l'afficheur qui tient ses
promesses voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors pour vous Yuma qui vous appelez
Myriam à l'époque c'est un saut
vertigineux dans la célébrité
instantanée en quelques heures des
propositions en tout genre se bousculent
mais vous vous en moquez vous continuez
à vivre votre passion pour le bouddhisme
vous préférez la spiritualité à la
célébrité et 30 ans après force est de
constater que c'était le bon choix
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à
20h
hum
a bonsoir
vous êtes né à Paris le 8 décembre
1961 sous le nom de Myriam sabot
votre père sculpteur hongrois bohème
utopiste
et votre mère a 17 ans la plus jolie
fille de Monparnasse ma mère était très
jeune et elle venait de subir une
déception amoureuse et mon père la
draguer dans le cimetière Montparnasse
et voilà alors quand vous naissez la
famille de votre mère arrange un mariage
avec un j.i américain les premières
années de votre vie se passent aux
États-Unis mais en arrivant là-bas le
mariage tarde à venir votre mère se
retrouve réceptionniste à l'hôtel
Sheraton et vous vous êtes blessé vous
vivez avec une vieille prostituée qui
elle-même vit avec son père paralytique
on dit une vieille prostitution mais en
fait c'était une femme extraordinaire
elle met du bien alors malgré tout vous
êtes scolarisé dans une école catholique
où vous découvrez la musique le cinéma
la danse de cette passion pour la danse
parce que quand votre mère se dispute
avec son j.i vous vous dansez tout le
temps quoi vous vous répondez à ça par
une danse permanente disons que
je danse donc oui
j'ai un peu tendance dans la rue
n'importe où à danser et donc quand
j'étais enfant je dansais partout dans
les escaliers dans les supermarchés
alors en 1969 c'est le retour en France
là vous allez apprendre la danse au
cours d'Irina grebina grande chorégraphe
russe
là vous devenez une espèce d'enfant
prodige qui cumulent la danse et les
études parce que vous êtes brillantes
aussi dans vos études mais à 14 ans vous
craquez et vous tombez amoureuse d'un
maori qui joue de la guitare dans le
métro je suis partie avec lui vous avis
14 ans il faut dire quand même à 14 ans
j'avais l'air d'avoir 18 ans
entre la peinture la guitare la prison
et l'héroïne alors vous amour hachez de
lui
vous discutez avec votre mère
et vous retrouvez à la rue
elle m'a mis à la porte mais elle le dit
elle-même elle pensait pas que je
partirai pour toujours alors là vous
faites la Manche pour payer la chambre
d'hôtel
mitesuse ou vous vivez avec avec votre
amant
et lui il fait des cambriolages assez
minables chez des gens qui qui vous
invite gentiment chez eux en fait ça
arrive aussi quand j'avais 14 ans on
était quand même encore assez je dirais
assez sain et puis petit à petit la
situation s'est détériorée de plus en
plus
surtout il devient machiavélique il vous
demande de ramener de jeunes vierges à
la maison ça vous
à l'époque
c'est pas je sais pas j'étais pas
formatée donc je ne sais pas comment
expliquer je n'avais pas les concepts
que les gens d'habitude et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je suis tombée
amoureuse avec cette personne c'est
quand sa présence tous mes concepts sont
tombés et j'ai aimé ça mais je voulais
qu'il m'aime et il me maltraitait donc
voilà
petit à petit de plus en plus horrible
un vrai cauchemar à l'époque des squats
et de la daube
mais automatiquement je m'arrêtais mais
je ne sais pas pourquoi j'étais comme ça
alors là vous inventez une combine assez
rigolote vous voulez des livres dans le
magasin
du boulevard Saint-Michel Gibert Jeune
et vous les revendez au même magasin
heureusement que j'ai mis un masque
aujourd'hui
vous tombez sur un livre qui va changer
votre vie ça s'appelle au-delà du
matérialisme spirituel de shogam
et vous devenez bouddhiste quand j'étais
enfant et que je dansais j'étais tout à
fait certaine que je cherchais quelque
chose donc j'étais née pour trouver
quelque chose et quand j'ai ouvert ce
livre c'était automatiquement c'est ça
c'est comme si vous voyez une photo de
votre maman vous savez que c'est elle
voilà donc dès que j'ai vu ce livre je
devais avoir 16 ans je savais que
c'était ça et je savais que je devais
changer de vie cette spiritualité
naissante va vous aider à échapper au
griffes de votre bourreau et à 17 ans
donc vous reprenez votre vie en main
dans les mois suivants vous dévorez tous
les livres que vous trouvez sur le
bouddhisme mais comme vous devez trouver
aussi une activité lucrative ce sera le
mannequinat et tout le monde m'a dit
qu'il n'y arriveras jamais
arrivé en septembre 1980 vous êtes
engagé dans une agence assez célèbre
j'avais mademoiselle qui était là la
filiale le prestige et là effectivement
vous découvrez le monde du mannequinat
avec des espèces de soirée rencontre qui
sont organisés par les agences pour que
les mannequins rencontrent au moins des
photographes et sans doute des dragueurs
comme je n'étais pas dupe on ne m'a
jamais harcelé en majuste de temps en
temps demander si je voulais pas un peu
changer d'avis mais effectivement il y
avait une espèce de marché comme ça
espèce de marché noir où les fêtes
commencer d'une façon assez normale et
probablement devait finir d'une autre
façon mais moi je partais toujours avant
que ça vienne
pas les discothèques non plus en tous
les cas c'est comme ça que vous allez
rencontrer Jean-François janvèle
célèbre photographe de l'époque ça
commence fort on fait des photos dans
elle je faisais surtout de la pub
mais vous êtes désolé par l'absurdité du
milieu de la publicité pour moi c'était
vraiment un travail alimentaire et donc
j'avais trouvé un système qui était
quand même merveilleux c'est que je
pouvais travailler deux trois mois et
arrêter de trois mois je partais en
retraite pour étudier le bouddhisme vous
décidez un jour de quitter Jean vert
vous lui t'écoute je veux plus te voir
parce que tu as une mauvaise influence
sur moi mais j'étais un peu je crois que
j'étais gentille ingénie mais en même
temps j'étais un peu arrogante et donc
je crois qu'à l'époque quand je lui dis
ça ça l'a vraiment vexé je pense
maintenant qu'il devait avoir 40 ans
j'en avais 18 donc évidemment je lui dis
ton genre de vie tu pratiques beaucoup
trop de choses qui sont à l'encontre de
l'éthique moi je veux développer dans la
mienne donc il faut que j'arrête de te
fréquenter et je l'ai fait et après il
m'a fait la gueule alors au printemps
1981 vous avez 19 ans vous faites un
casting pour l'agence CLN c'est une
campagne pour l'afficheur à venir vous
voyez surtout les
Franck ça peut vous rapporter pour
financer votre prochaine retraite en
fait oui j'avais un projet c'était de
passer deux mois dans les montagnes et
il fallait que je paye je paye mon loyer
à Paris pour cela le problème de cette
affiche c'est que le photographe c'est
Jean vert que vous venez de quitter
alors il est pas très chaud évidemment
pour vous engager il y a deux rivales
qui sont devant vous mais la chance que
vous avez d'une certaine façon c'est que
l'une son père refuse et l'autre c'est
son petit ami qui refuse donc ils ont
été obligé de me prendre
je sais pas très douée enfin maintenant
si j'étais pas très doué pour dire et
vous partez au Bahamas vous faites 48
heures de bronzage intégral et puis une
photo commence et c'était marrant parce
que pendant que je pensais c'était
interdit de faire le bronzage intégral
et donc Joël Lebert et Jean-François
jovel ils regardaient s'il avait pas de
policiers moi je faisais
alors voilà en fait vous comprendrez
plus tard vous avez été un petit peu
arnaqué dans cette campagne parce que
finalement vous n'avez pas touché autant
que ce qu'elle a rapporté aux gens
qu'ils l'ont fait c'est certain la
campagne sort la première c'est le 2
septembre j'enlève le haut
le 4 septembre j'enlève le bas alors moi
je m'en souviens mais quand même
magnifique on était tous comme des
malades et le 4 septembre voilà ce qu'on
voit donc
l'afficheur qui tient ses promesses
voilà moi c'est beau hein
[Applaudissements]
incroyable campagne alors évidemment les
féministes Jean Gisèle Halimi vêtroudi
sans mêle disent que c'est un scandale
il y a même des endroits où des villes
où on colle des papiers sur les fesses
et une grosse polémique finalement pour
une campagne qui aura duré quoi dix
jours c'est extraordinaire et c'est un
une histoire qu'on étudie toujours dans
les écoles de communication parce que
avec très peu d'argent ils sont arrivés
à faire un événement
national voilà alors quand la campagne
sort en fait vous vous êtes en train de
méditer en arrière
sans électricité sans téléphone vous
êtes prévenus en fait par un télégramme
la boucleuse qui vous demande de revenir
immédiatement à Paris toute la presse
parle de toi toutes les radios parlent
de toi donc voilà je n'ai jamais vu les
affiches moi
j'ai jamais vu la vraie affiche énorme
je ne l'ai jamais vu et voilà donc j'ai
dû rentrer à Paris alors là évidemment
quand vous arrivez à Paris il y a des
demandes d'interview de tout le monde
mais vous refusez de faire de la
télévision ou une fête que de la presse
et de la radio pour éviter d'être
emmerdé c'est malin ça si je voulais pas
qu'on me reconnaisse alors là les
propositions les plus saugrenues
pleuvent
Polnareff qui évidemment lui s'était
montré cunu sur une affiche donc il vous
dit pourquoi on fait pas un coup
ensemble Yves Simon qui vous propose
d'écrire un livre en fait vous comprenez
assez rapidement que c'est pas juste
pour écrire un livre et même Patrick
Sabatier veut prendre une mission de
télé projet de télé je ne sais pas ce
que c'était mais on n'a jamais parlé en
fait alors là il y a un réalisateur de
cinéma qui s'appelle René Ferré qui est
très connu qui veut faire un film avec
vous une vie de Maupassant il dit où je
fais le film avec toi où je le fais pas
le tournage doit démarrer le 16 août ça
tombe mal parce que vous aviez prévu une
retraite
vous lui demandez de repousser le
tournage il dit non mais ça va pas on
part pousser le tournage pour ta
retraite mais vous tenez bon
j'ai raccroché la page était tournée
quand même pour moi c'était très clair
que le sens de ma vie est
la pratique spirituelle vers laquelle
j'étais en train de m'élancer était
beaucoup plus importante que tout le
reste et c'était tellement important
pour moi que je pensais si je meurs
demain je ne veux pas être en tournage
je vais en retraite
de plus en plus contente alors voilà
c'est un livre que je recommande ça
s'appelle la voix qui danse par Yuma
mudra puisque c'est votre nom désormais
et c'est publié chez François bourin
vous êtes une publicité vivante pour le
bouddhisme parce que vous avez une telle
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu